first up though correspondent Molly line
in West Mifflin Pennsylvania tonight
where they could be looking at new jobs
good evening Molly
good evening Brett
well impassioned critics including a
chorus of voices from the president's
own party have decried his steep tariffs
on steel and aluminum many of those who
still work at a dwindled number of
plants here in Pennsylvania feel hope I
think it's a that's an extra shot in the
arm for us we need the all the job
security we can get Scott Storch works
for US Steel in West Mifflin and he's
the president of the local Steel Workers
Union he believes the president's tariff
plan will give the industry a
much-needed boost every time we get a
move like yet with extra security with
tariffs it brings new higher reason it
creates a lot of job opportunity for the
valley he traveled to Washington today
to watch the president put pen to paper
the storage family like many steel clans
across the Mon Valley understand what it
means to have a good job in steel and
what it means to lose one as his father
did nearly 40 years ago I never forgot
that looking into his eyes in my
household what that does to a family you
hear about it but when you're actually
involved and it impacts you it's it'll
never leave you in the wake of World War
2 s war mobilization Pennsylvania's
steel industry thrived until the early
80s an unprecedented gush of cheap
foreign steel flooded the world market
and like dominoes the plants and mills
that dotted these mountains shut down
George's dad Herrmann sarch remembers
the shattering blow it was a shocking
reality for a lot of people maybe eight
or nine hundred guys where do you go now
the father of six soft friends lose cars
homes and marriages and says the region
has never recovered these towns have all
turned into ghost towns I mean really
the Rust Belt is amazing and now it's
all drug infested it's hard it's just a
hard place to try to live and survive
but this family is not giving up and
Scott Storch believes the future of
Steel is strong maybe you'll see some of
these cities and towns clean up and
you'll see people walk around with hope
US Steel employs more than 3000 people
in its facilities here in the Mon Valley
the big question of course is whether
these tariffs will mean new jobs a
spokesperson says that they do
anticipate an increased demand for steel
produced in the United States and says
if that demand is sustained the company
will respond and staff up to meet
customer needs
Brett my line live in Pennsylvania Molly
thank you